sky's greg milan reports from texas
where he's witnessed an active shooter
training exercise designed to prevent
the events we saw in uvalde
it is a sad reality in america that
exercises like this in a mock classroom
are so essential
[Music]
responding officers training how to
tackle a gunman
this center which sets the national
standard for dealing with active
shooters is just a hundred miles from
uvalde
the police admission that they got it
wrong in waiting to confront the gunman
at the robb elementary school has raised
the possibility that their decision cost
lives
police in uvalde say they were trained
but it's clear something went
catastrophically wrong
with two decades of experience in swat
teams john kernet says that shouldn't
have happened
you've been in that situation what do
you think went wrong on tuesday i
understand why it was difficult what
they were put into the situation they
were put into
but i understand that we know enough
about these incidents that we should be
training for stuff like this
the plan a doesn't work what's the plan
b c d
we have to have
these capabilities it's required of us
winston churchill
once said
sometimes doing your best isn't good
enough sometimes you must do what is
required
i sense as a country that this is a
watershed moment for a lot of people
every single one of these is a watershed
moment for us in this business every
single one of these
breaks our heart and chews up our soul
just a little bit each time this happens
and we want to make sure that if we
can't prevent them we're darn sure going
to respond to them to the best of our
ability ultimately it was salvador ramos
who was responsible for what happened on
tuesday but his actions have raised so
many questions for america the president
among those who need to provide the
answers as i speak
those parents are literally preparing to
bury their children
in the united states america to bury
their children
too much violence
too much fear
too much grief
let's be
clear evil came to that elementary
school classroom in texas
he'll travel to texas to show support
for the community of uvalde and the
families of those who died to a small
town now forever associated with an
appalling act of violence
and another moment of reckoning for this
country greg milam sky news texas